[Music]  hey kids wow you've got quite a spread  here so too much  stand down Greg look at this a  mysterious disturbance recently took  place in the town of Madison Delaware  preachers come alive from the original  manuscripts before I'll sign the book  what book it's a goose box box box what  did you do it's time to make  go get the string  we're living a goosebumps story right  now I hear it's a real scream  Halloween is alive I know it's my  favorite holiday - you're gonna need  some serious therapy addition that book  is the only thing we have to end this  let's go  [Music]  someone's gonna win our costume contest  goosebumps Halloween  all these gummy bears  [Music]